welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about whether
humanity will be destroyed by being
washed out at sea swallowed by a
volcanic pit
or eaten to death by insects
my name's mt and i'm here with
off-screen producer brandon how are you
doing today brandon
mt i'm doing great so glad to be back
doing another big question with you it's
hey if you guys don't know brandon was
the first person i ever did a big
question with and he is the man oh
you're too kind but yes as mobius and
loki searched for the locust loki
variant along the sacred timeline they
also presented us with a pretty bleak
future full of apocalyptic
but not planet-ending events that got us
thinking about this week's big question
could the apocalyptic events in loki
possibly be
our bleak future ugh there were bleak
empties like super like some were even
like 30
years away like the roxanne thing was
like 30 years away right yeah
yeah well guess what mt it's time to
pull up
rem on spotify because it's the end of
the world as we know it and i
don't feel fine oh no me neither no
oh boy yeah this is gonna be this could
be some heavy stuff as loki was chasing
down the variant that was hiding and
naturally occurring apocalyptic events
on the planet
we got a quick glimpse from both loki
and mobius
about some of the possible awful
calamities in our future
okay so we're gonna take today's big q
and we're gonna like look at the
likelihood of these events happening
and what history might tell us of the
outcomes if they do occur
okay okay yeah it's gonna get a little
dark
okay we're gonna be discussing some real
world events where innocent people who
are just going about their daily lives
were wiped out
but just like mobius express to the
minute man we're gonna be as respectful
as we can
yes uh we can't change history mt but we
can learn from it
we can't change history yet brandon yes
remember yet not until we get that power
exactly should be like next week
you're gonna get the power to go back in
time uh next week yeah i order
off amazon it should be around of course
bezos can go back bezels
every time they set up a union he goes
back in time and destroys it oh my god
he's gonna listen to this
i think we're dead now the bezos is
coming after us
i know my alexa's looking at me
listening extra hard now
okay so we're gonna go in chronological
order of the events
that occurred on the sacred timeline
between 2047 and
2051 according to the tva archives or
what we heard loki and mobius talk about
so let's start with the climate disaster
of 2048
all right woo clapping disaster tester
this one was pretty
vague okay it's just listed as a climate
disaster so that could mean a lot of
things
a majority of real scientists not those
fake ass scientists
but real scientists agree that rising
global temperatures from carbon
emissions
could lead to devastating planetary
situations such as rising sea levels and
extreme weather events
in 2015 you might remember we had the
paris climate accords
which led to the creation of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change or the ipcc for short the good
old live pcc
you down with ipcc yeah you know me
you know what ipcc yeah you know me yeah
you know me
the goal coming out of the paris
agreement was to prevent a rising global
temperatures from
1.5 degrees celsius above pre-industrial
levels
it doesn't seem like a lot but this is
like a global average so it'll be higher
in some places lower in other places
right
um to do this we need to cut greenhouse
gas emissions globally
now why you may ask 1.5 degrees
uh specifically well scientists agree
that once we reach like that 1.5 degree
threshold globally
there would be enough heat to push many
of the natural systems that sustain life
on this planet
past the point of no return oh so if we
go past that 1.5 degree rise in global
temperatures
the impact of climate events around the
world would go from being like pretty
destructive
to absolutely catastrophic uh
great so yes like we've already seen
some effects of like
rising temperatures and you know weather
patterns are getting more severe but if
we go past that 1.5 degrees celsius rise
it's you know like it's gonna be the
whole
toilet paper fiasco times a million yeah
yeah you remember trying to buy toilet
paper imagine that you ain't gonna find
no toilet paper during the apocalypse
baby
none you'll be eating toilet paper if
you're watching we will be the toilet
paper the wet toilet paper
we're done we're the earth's toilet
paper
and the earth is going to wipe its ass
with us pretty much
pretty much uh so in 2018 the ipcc
released a report
that laid out what could happen if
global temperatures rise
past that 1.5 degree danger here's some
of the highlights
1.7 billion more people would experience
severe heat waves at least
once every five days damn so people are
people already having extreme heat waves
you know people in cities die from heat
waves
even in the good old usfa if there's a
heat wave you know people
usually die 1.7 billion more people
would experience those heat waves bro
at least once every fight over active
sweat glands my dude i can't do that
so that's that's one of the things okay
another thing uh
the seas would rise on average another
10 centimeters which is like almost four
inches
which doesn't sound like a lot but again
any a lot of places
on the coast are at sea level so four
inches it starts coming up
and this is again averaging out some
places it'll be much higher some places
will be much lower i would agree that
four inches is a lot my friend
i would tend to agree that four inches
is very
uh significant and uh four inches
it's a lot everywhere if there's
anything that we can take from this
video but that four inches
is a lot until any sort of measurement
whatever you measure four inches it's
extreme
all right sorry i'm just being 12.
continue
up to 700 million more people would
become exposed to climate-related risks
and poverty
the coral reefs that support marine
environments around the world would
decline as much as
99 i know i love the cool groups the
coral reefs they're like the heart of
the ocean you know they're the
great they're great to look at but they
all serve as a function it's all part of
the immune system
okay and then another another problem
would be global fishery catches would
decline by
1.5 million tons another one point
they're already declining
they would decline by another 1.5
million tons
people eat fish you eat fish some salmon
it's delicious yeah well say goodbye to
it
so we have like so so we passed this 1.5
degrees right
the oceans rise the coral reefs die this
affects ecosystems worldwide
like right now about 40 percent of the
world's population
live within 60 miles of the coast okay
so imagine those seas coming out those
people got to go somewhere
so we're going to see like more global
poverty more global
mass migration caused by climate change
and on top of that we'll have these
extreme heat waves that could be
experienced around the world
so you'd have devastating effects on
agriculture and food production
so rising past that 1.5 degree warning
line could lead to an extinction level
event
and maybe not humans being extinct at
first but certainly
important species that are part of the
ecosystem would go extinct
and this would just cascade and cause
all sorts of problems
uh and probably doom us humans to be
that toilet paper scenario we're talking
even
[Music]
stinky people you might as well just
kill me because i don't want to live in
a world of stuff bring on the meteor why
not the meteor lord
so this climate disaster of 2048 what's
the likelihood
that this could happen i mean given
humanity's past behavior in
transgressions
high i would agree pretty damn tend to
agree unfortunately
i mean we couldn't even get people to
put masks on how are we going to expect
them to like cut back on their needs
it's true it's so true like that's
exactly the one thing i've been thinking
about after all of 2020 is like bro
we can't even do the simplest thing how
are we going to stop climate change
anyway so i think loki might be right on
the money with this one the tva is right
20 48
watch out folks everybody go to roxcart
just grab what you need so the next the
next catastrophic event on the tv's list
was the eruption of krakatoa and twenty
my favorite spongebob hero
sorry i just spongebob reference iphone
i mean
spongebob is like the blind spot of my
trivia
i don't know my my spongebob trivia you
watch
well so 2049 we have the eruption of
krakatoa krakatoa erupted
in 2049 as well so krakatoa has already
had a major
eruption once before back in 1883.
so we can look at the history of that to
get a sense what might happen
when it erupts again because krakatoa
will have another big eruption
at some point in its lifespan i remember
reading about krakatoa as a kid and it
freaked
me bro okay i was living in florida
where there are
zero volcanoes and zero chances for
volcanoes but i read about krakatoa
issa java uh and i was sure that that
volcano was gonna just like open up in
my backyard and
it could happen you never know you never
know the chances are
not zero i mean they are pretty zero
it's not zero it's close to zero
[Music]
so krakatoa if you don't know it's
located in the sunda strait which is in
between two of indonesia's largest
islands
uh the eruption in krakatoa in 1883 was
one of the deadliest and most
destructive volcanic events in recorded
history
uh it was long too it was a really long
kind of eruption it started in may
but like the biggest and most
devastating explosion
didn't happen until august so it's like
it was like kind of slowly erupting
slowly happening and then boom [ __ ] goes
off in august so the big explosion that
happens was heard almost 2 000 miles
away in perth australia
what and another three yeah another 3
000 miles away
in mauritius they heard it get out of
the tower yo 2 000 by how
how loud was that like 10 miles away
that wasn't been crazy
well here's the thing the sound wave of
the largest eruption
is recorded to travel the globe like
seven times over
like it just like went around the earth
like just grow
my for real yeah sailors who were on
boats like 50 miles away
from the volcano obviously you see it
they hear it and they lost their sense
of hearing
bro we should have saw that in loki
instead that would be way cooler
i mean like apocalypses are bad well
that's why he went to vesuvius
and not krakatoa yo that is the most
mind-blowing fact
that saturday fact is killing me right
now wow so krakatoa explodes boom
you looking for this the records say
like over 36 000 deaths are attributed
to like the eruption and the resulting
tsunamis
so like over 300 towns and villages were
destroyed along like the strait
where the island is because the tsunami
kind of like traveled about that
straight
uh and one one tsunami was created by
pieces of the volcano like collapsing
into the sea
and it was like 125 feet 120 feet high
which is about as tall as a six-story
building so just imagine that big wave
heading towards you
you're some you're some guy you live in
near krakatoa
you hear this thing oh that sounded
awful i hope i'll be okay and then just
good job
grandpa you're telling me that all of
this terrible sh this is going to happen
again
one of these days yeah it could happen
again i'm glad you asked yes
uh because it's krakatoa like still
erupts like
periodically with like smaller eruptions
like there was eruptions in 2009 2010
2011 2012 2018 and as recently as 2020
there was like another small eruption
but now
so we've been having all of these close
calls this entire time
yeah but i think that's good you want
because volcano the dangerous thing with
volcanoes is like pressure and time
right and the more the pressure builds
up the more the bigger the explosion is
going to be
so i think these little eruptions are
good if if there was going to be another
huge eruption like there was in 1883
we'd probably have some advanced warning
because remember i said it started in
may but then really erupted in august
they just didn't know
what was going on back then so now we
probably have some advanced warning
but even with a heads up we could still
see like a massive loss of life
and definitely it's something like
intense destruction and then another
thing to consider is all the ash
and volcanic gases that get dumped into
the atmosphere
like if you see a painting of krakatoa
it has like this huge
plume coming up and all that stuff like
affects the climate temporarily around
the earth like
it would cool temperatures in the
northern hemisphere as like sulfuric
gases from the volcano
would go up into the clouds and it would
make the clouds more reflective
and so it diverts like the earth's
sunlight away from the earth like
cooling the earth
uh so that's a problem and in our more
populated modern world
like these temporary climate changes
could cause more casualties than they
did
holy [ __ ] what
yeah yo don't mess with me i do not have
a fear of krakatoa before this video and
now i do
holy moly wow you know i was scared so
that eruption that happens in 1883
it caused orange orange skies like
these beautiful orange skies around the
world for like
days months afterwards because it's
dumping all this gas into the atmosphere
so especially in like the morning and in
the evenings when the sun was rising and
setting they'd have these beautiful
orange skies
and then at night the moon was said to
look blue instead of
like the kind of grayish silver it looks
now because there's all these different
gases in the atmosphere
in fact in fact if you've ever seen that
um the painting by edvard munch
that dude who's like on the bridge and
he's right screaming the sky is like
really orange and yellow in that
painting
and it's thought that he the artist
he based that orange sky off the sky he
saw in norway because of christianity he
lived in norway
krakatoa is down in indonesia he's
getting this orange sky because he
finished the painting in
uh 18 okay 93. so that was like 10 years
after so
in norway they were seeing these orange
skies in 1883 and 1884. so like that's
how effective i mean if you survive the
volcano i feel like your instagram is
going to be popping with
amazing pictures great sunsets
no all four survivors you know you will
be blowing up
that's all we need to focus on with
these apocalypse how will my instagram
fare
how will i capitalize this can i put an
ad
on this apocalypse sponsored post
and i don't know if you remember mt but
in 2010 there was that big
volcano in iceland i'm not going to try
to pronounce it that
it started erupting and in effect like
travel in and out of europe they had to
cancel flights and divert flights
because planes couldn't fly you can't
fly through like this volcanic smoke
so again that would be like another
problem that would be caused by this it
would
disrupt international travel so krakatoa
it's definitely going to erupt again
it's going to have another big eruption
like an 18 don't jinx it man that's
scary it's going to happen tomorrow
it's also it's also worth noting uh that
a volcano is believed not krakatoa but a
volcano is believed to be the
the cause of the largest of the five
mass extinctions on earth
there's been like five mass extinctions
on earth and the largest one happened
250 million years ago
and it was the permian triassic
extinction
and they scientists think like it was
caused by a volcano doing that like
dumping stuff in the atmosphere totally
changing the climate and like killing
off
a lot of the living creatures on the
plot on the planet
it was about don't mess with volcanoes
jurassic park terrible time
so we'll list we'll list this one you
know the re-eruption of krakatoa it's a
possibility don't
don't you dare put that curse on me
brandon we don't need the krakatoa i'm
scared of krakatoa now
wow i thought queen was just a spongebob
i mean fun little joke
it was not a joke oh jeez it's not funny
so next time you're in the air volcano
you know maybe make a human sacrifice
to the volcano guides to please please
please set off krakatoa again
our next apocalyptic event it's the
extinction of the swallow
in 2050. 2050 the extinction of the
swallow
that i think completely screwed up the
ecosystem uh swallows a really cute
little bird if you're not familiar but
uh yeah this one sounds sad but you
might be thinking that's just a bird i
care about birds birds are
amazing the bird is the word birds are
beautiful
birds are important bird is the word as
we're all aware you know the animals in
the natural world they exist in a
delicate balance
this whole thing should be you know
we've always seen
the hierarchy of species you know
there's uh
a food chain you know humans sitting at
the top eating on mcdonald's
and it's all the species all all the
animals they benefit from each other in
different ways
uh and when one element of the food
chain gets totally out of land they can
throw the whole system into chaos
uh and birds are very important part of
this balance and we can look to history
to see just how
important one single bird species could
be i'm going to take you all the way
back to 19
1958 okay when the leader of china
mao zedong you may have heard him okay
uh he launched
the four pests campaign and this was
like part of his
his like effort to kind of grow china
and bring them into
a more industrialized future but the
four pest campaign was designed to
encourage the people of china to help
eradicate
four types of animals that they saw as
pests uh three of those animals were
mosquitos flies and rats
all because they spread diseases such as
typhoid malaria and the plague
and you know yeah we're all done with
mosquitoes no real benefit really
what are they doing they're not making
honey well you can make the art so
it's female mosquitoes that drink blood
male mosquitoes they drink like plant
juice and
some male mosquitoes they help with the
pollination of plants because they're
drinking that plant
okay so down with the patriarchy unless
you're a mosquito
gotcha the mosquito patriarchy is all
right they're just eating plant juice
guys
yeah the female mosquitoes are drinking
that blood so those were three of the
animals okay the fourth pest
in the for pest campaign was the sparrow
uh more specifically the eurasian tree
sparrow this
cute little bird why did they hate this
bird it wasn't because it was spreading
diseases the government at the time
thought that the sparrows were eating
important crops such as rice and grains
we gotta get rid of them
so the citizens are encouraged to kill
the sparrows on site like shoot them out
of the air
or at very least like start banging pots
and pans to keep them from nesting in
trees
and so that they'd constantly be flying
around and just like
that's so sad which is so tense
it's like get out of here yeah criminal
there was one instance where it was like
an embassy in china i think it was like
the
polish embassy or someone they had a
bunch of sparrows in their tree and all
of these citizens from these chinese
citizens like came around and started
banging pots and pans
and like the embassy would not let them
on the property they're like not coming
in here with that [ __ ] so they stood
around the whole embassy for days
just banging the pots and pans like
insanity wow
cause they thought they were being good
citizens is what their leader told them
to do
so this started in 1958 by 1960 the
eurasian tree sparrow was like nearly
merely
jason sparrow so like they did it right
problem solved
okay no more problems more problems so
it turns out that the sparrow's effect
on the crops from like eating it was
negligible they were barely eating the
crops
what sparrows like to eat are insects
specifically
locusts and so now that you've killed
all your sparrows
the locust population exploded and
plagues of locusts like wiped out the
crops doing way more damage than the
birds ever did the sparrow extinction
was one of the contributing factors to
the great chinese famine of 1959 to
1961. there was a lot of things that led
to this famine i'm not claiming it's
just the sparrow but it did not help
that they killed off the sparrow
and had these lego logos which ate all
their crops the great chinese famine
led to the death of anywhere from 15
million
citizens to 45 million chinese citizens
it's hard to say because the chinese
government yeah you know they didn't
want to say how many people died but
the low ball they gave us was 15 million
and then a lot of historians think it's
closer to like 45 million chinese
citizens
holy smokes you guys banged your pots
and pans to death
god damn that is so crazy
they did that in like two years they
wiped out like a whole species of bird
and that's just one example from history
in one country
so what about our poor swallows future
is there any chance for the swallow
we're at least not out there shooting
them we're not banging our pots and pans
that's
a good step yeah that's a good first
step in the right direction but already
um you know the annual migration of the
swallow has been affected by global
warming
our good friend uh and other human
factors such as like chemicals
insecticides pesticides and habitat
destruction have reduced the swallow
population by
30 percent over the last decade boo
humanity boom
boom humanity so swallows if you don't
know they they migrate between france
and africa
they they like fly back and forth like
it's over 6 000 miles that they migrate
and you know what swallows like to eat
empty they like to eat
insects yeah so if the swallow
populations continue to decline we could
see a rise in
insect populations in multiple countries
which
you know not okay and so by overusing
insecticides we wind up killing the
insects that the swallows eat
or sometimes the swallows still eat the
insects but they ingest like the harmful
chemicals and it gets passed into their
digestive system and it kills them off
so if we don't do something to help
bring their populations back we could
see
continual decline of the swallow and
have long-term effects on the ecosystem
so hashtag save the swallow yo we gotta
save these birds man
god they'll be killing all these insects
hashtags for real we got to save that
swallow
you're you're killing me with these
facts man let's go i know it's
depressing this is a depressing
loki is a depressing if you have anxiety
leave now
or leave several minutes ago
rewind go back in time and leave exactly
um so i'm going to rate the
extinction of the swallow in 2050 as
very likely oh no
i'm very worried all right i was not
that worried i thought it was like a
funny joke but now i'm like very
yo it is yeah i'm not trying to deal
with locusts y'all i ain't trying to
make this into the book of exodus
let's just save these birds yeah save
these birds you saw the cicadas this
year
that was crazy and their cicadas are
harmless wait until the locusts come
yeah it's gonna be
devastating okay
so our next our next planetary
apocalyptic event this one we we really
saw play out in the show this is the
category eight hurricane of 2015.
okay now i myself i'm originally from
florida so i've lived through my fair
share of hurricane seasons and let me
tell you if you don't know hurricanes
suck they are awful they're scary
they're huge they take
they they last so long it's they're not
fun they're not fun
um and as the climate gets warmer
hurricanes get stronger
uh because hurricanes they build power
over the ocean they're sucking up the
warm air and they get powerful and more
powerful
and when a hurricane hits land it starts
to lose its strength and like eventually
it dissipates
but as the planet continues to warm the
hurricanes retain more power
as they come ashore so they're getting
more powerful and they're staying more
powerful and doing more damage as they
pass
inland so right now we rank hurricanes
on a scale from one to five it maxes out
at five
and to give you an idea a category one
hurricane has sustained wind speeds of
74 to 95 miles per hour
uh and a storm surge of four to five
feet now storm surge
is the rise in the level of water above
norm above the normal tide
uh as the ocean water gets pushed inland
by the storm like hurricane is so strong
the wind is so powerful it's pushing the
water of the ocean like just inland
and as you know most coastal areas are
pretty much at sea level so
even a category one with four to five
feet that can go pretty far
yeah like
houses destroyed and now a category five
hurricane has winds
of 156 miles per hour plus and a storm
surge of
19 feet plus yeah what huge
so right now like i said the the the
table maxes out at five the category
maxes out at
five so if we were to like extrapolate
the current scale up to a category oh no
this is nice it would be a hurricane
that has sustained wind speeds of 246
to 324 miles per hour
okay and a storm surge of 30 to 40 feet
wow so that's 30 to 40 feet above the
normal tide level
so like i'm pretty sure that would wipe
out most of florida just with
storm surge i don't know if anywhere in
florida gets above like 40
don't even play let's not even entertain
the idea of a category eight
that's like insane isn't it 247 miles
per hour on the
lower end that's the low end yeah yeah
this would be like an extremely
destructive hurricane uh
now in loki we saw that the event report
said that over ten thousand people died
in haven hills alabama
that's like a pretty accurate
representation of the destruction a
coastal city would face from like a
category
devastating hurricane that's devastating
yeah and you gotta imagine it would be
like huge it's not just gonna hit one
town it's gonna hit like
multiple towns now buildings in
hurricane prone areas are tend to be
built to like a certain code to
withstand
tropical events and we can think that by
2050 we might have stronger building
materials
but even then it's still like an
extremely devastating storm with like
tons of wind damage and severe coastal
flooding now you might be thinking well
is a category 8 hurricane even possible
by 2050
it could we it's the earth gonna get
warm enough to get us there
and i would say most definitely um uh
in 2019 we had hurricane dorian which is
one of the strongest storms ever
recorded in
in the atlantic and it reached sustained
wind speeds of 185 miles per hour
which if the hurricane scale didn't
currently max out at five if they kept
going up that would have been a category
six
it technically was but because it's not
on the scale yet we still called a
category five
but it was like pretty much a category
so i'm gonna rate
you know the category eight hurricane of
2050 as
very great this could be in our future i
think
we can see it oh boy oh hot dog i can't
wait for that
guys stop driving in your cars get a
bike seriously let's all just bike
to work i'm sorry this is the most
depressing thank you you're gonna see
this [ __ ] oh bro
i hope boy okay on to our next
apocalyptic event
another one they mentioned was well the
tsunami of 2051 let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go this one was pretty
generic we didn't hear much she just
said the tsunami of 2051.
we've already discussed the threat of
like rising ocean levels from climate
change
but the sudden rising of ocean levels
from like a tsunami would be
catastrophic you know in recent history
we've seen the destructive nature of
tsunamis you know there was of course a
tsunami in japan
that happened in 2011 which was caused
by an earthquake underwater that was
a 9.0 to a 9.1 and then if you remember
in 2004
there was another tsunami caused by an
underwater earthquake in the indian
ocean that one was a
scientists aren't quite sure but it's
like somewhere between a 9.1
and a 9.3 so huge huge underwater
earthquake i forgot about this like that
tsunami
in 2004 killed over 277
000 people yeah i was in the sixth grade
and like you know being in sixth grade
you don't really watch
the news but that is what everyone was
talking about yeah you could not have
not heard about the tsunami it was
devastating i don't
and i don't even remember like you know
you heard about tsunamis but like
that was you know in our lifetime a real
world example of just how dangerous it
is
that tsunami in 2004 did over 15 billion
dollars in damage
and the earthquake that caused it was
like the third largest ever recorded
and created tsunamis over 100 feet high
over 100 feet high it was one of the
deadliest natural disasters in recorded
history bro that is hell on earth bro
that is hell on earth
holy [ __ ] sorry i guess i'm swearing
i mean that's that's worth only i think
so again like devastating
you know you can't imagine what it would
be like to have something like that
happen
i guess the positive is the human
sitting closet it's not our fault
like that's just one of those things
like i don't think you can blame that on
climate change or anything it's just
that's how the earth works and you know
earthquake's gonna earthquake
uh and it's gonna cause tsunamis but
yeah man it's scary
there's nothing we can really do to
prevent one of those happening again
like it certainly could happen again
but all we can do is continue to be
scientists you know let's continue to
study seismic events
and improve early warning systems like
that's the most important thing
having ways to evacuate people who live
on the coast knowing ahead of time
you know oh there's this big earthquake
under water we got to get people away
from the coast like that's the most we
can do
to help save lives and help prevent like
these huge disasters from happening
again
also we can tell our upstairs neighbors
to stop stomping so loud
um that would be a really big help with
earthquakes
thank god my upstairs neighbors are not
in an ocean because they would cause
every day yeah i feel like i feel like
this is an upstairs neighbor thing to do
i feel like they all just gather around
in a secret society like how hard should
we stomp on christmas
how big should we make our shoes we need
to make our shoes look every size
we are the upstairs neighbors and we
will make noise
the evil cabal of upstairs neighbors
they're worse
number one worse so i'm gonna list uh
the tsunami of 2051 as a possibility
you know yeah unfortunately the only
thing i can suggest
everyone move to kansas get away from
the coast i mean that should be the
state slogan of
kansas kansas don't worry about the
tsunamis
and the wizard of oz wasn't real it
wasn't a real movie so don't worry about
the tornadoes
kansas didn't work out well for the
clutters but you know
that's a cold blood joke cut that kids
don't read in cold blood they don't know
the clutches
yet it's a great book if you haven't
read it highly recommend it really
kicked off the
the crime genre the true crowd great
stuff uh so the last
apocalyptic event this one they
technically didn't give a date to
but when loki was doing his uh you know
ragnarok on mobius's salad he mentions
when he's listing off like what could be
apocalyptic events
he mentioned supernovas um and i've
always like kind of been interested in
supernovas so i'm gonna include
supernovas on the list
so this apocalyptic event would be a
supernova near earth like close enough
to do damage to earth now
you might be asking yourself brandon
what is a supernova well
a supernova is the explosion of a star
and it's the largest explosion that
happens in space uh
so stars are kind of confusing there's
all types of different stars
um and i barely understood what i was
reading about stars
but a supernova is like part of the
death sequence of a star
so a star has like all these elements
inside of it and it's it's huge
like the sun our sun is considered a
pretty small star but you could fit like
something like a million earths inside
of it but it was a million it's huge
right
oh is it a million one they got one more
in there just cramming one more in there
i was like we have room
the stars have like all these elements
inside of them uh
in fact like every element that's on
earth comes from exploded stars
you know what i mean uh nitrogen
hydrogen
gold silver wood is it all comes from
stars
we're all made of exploded stars baby uh
you're a star i'm a star
everyone uh you're a star if you're in
the comments saying bad things you're
not a star but it's okay but you can be
a star if you'd be better so
so a star has all these elements and
it's it's big so it's like heavy and all
these elements are getting pushed
towards the center of the star
uh by gravity and so they're smashing
together and like you have nuclear
fusion going on inside
of the star but eventually they the star
runs out of elements to fuel itself
and so it kind of explodes like
everything
kind of crashes into each other and it
explodes so that's the supernova
star's dying when a star does go
supernova it can be seen you can see it
in the sky like from earth it'll be like
an extremely bright light
uh it'll be like one of the brightest
things you would see at night and
sometimes you can even see him during
the day and we know this because like
throughout
ancient history you know different
astronomers from different parts of the
world
you know they watched the stars a lot
they had no tv they had no internet so
they had to watch the star show
and it's every day and they kept track
and you know that
they lived by the stars uh so they would
notice when like there was a new bright
ass star
in the sky and they'd be like where the
heck does this come from i guess we
should kill a bunch of people because
god's angry or something
um but so we know we you know we can
look at history
and then astronomers have gone back and
said like oh this you know this ancient
society they saw this random star for a
couple weeks
um and then we realized by looking into
space and like looking at the history of
light and all that stuff in space like
oh it was a supernova they saw a
supernova
and so sometimes they've happened and
they haven't had much effect on earth
because they've been so far away and
you know it's not really hurting us but
what if a star
near earth went supernova um if a star
that was um kind of that was closer than
eight parsecs to earth which is twenty
parsecs are real what parsecs are real
i know it sounds like a fancy term okay
i had no idea continue
so if i start if a star that's within
eight parsecs
of earth go supernova it would destroy
half of the earth's ozone layer just
like all the radiation would just like
destroy the ozone layer
you'd be like oh that's probably a bad
idea right it's a horrible idea
um because this would expose earth to
like harmful cosmic and solar radiation
uh and it would be really devastating to
the ocean like the phytoplankton
and like all the little creatures on the
the reefs our beloved coral reefs
uh that use light to fuel themselves it
would just like wipe them out
and that that would totally destroy the
marine ecosystem and then destroy the
rest of
earth's ecosystem a nearby supernova is
thought to be the cause of the late
ordovician mass extinction that occurred
on earth
450 to 440 million million years ago
this supernova exploded and dumped tons
of gamma radiation on earth
killing off over 60 of the oceanic life
on earth and i think most of life at
that time was oceanic
so this was the second largest of the
earth's five mass extinctions if you
remember i brought up the mass
extinctions earlier wow this was number
two uh and they believe it was caused by
a supernova that was close enough to
earth that it
sent so much gamma radiation to earth it
wiped out
most of the life on the planet like
totally changing the trajectory on life
like if this hadn't happened maybe yes
smart apes wouldn't be here you know
what i mean because the ocean life would
have just prospered wow
it would have been aquaman in this [ __ ]
it's like it's just so crazy
like just how fragile like our earth is
because like anything like it's just
crazy how everything works
out like even though like things are
starting to degrade
the fact that like we've had such a
perfect earth for such a long time
is incredible yeah where our our
existence of life on this planet is just
but a mere blip you know
the earth's been around for a long time
and there's been these mass extinctions
and like other
species other types of life didn't get a
chance to thrive
uh and we're we're hanging on there by a
friend
so the bad news is we can't really
predict what star will go supernova
or when it might happen but astronomers
are pretty confident that there are no
stars
close enough to earth to do any serious
damage in the near future
that's good um so we should be okay for
our lifetime i don't know about like our
great grandkids but hey man
them kids bro buy a star suit kid
come on no i agree hashtag
them kids but what a sunset what a
sunset indeed
yeah so the next time you're out there
and you're wishing upon a star
you know maybe wish for it to have a
long happy life cycle
yeah so i'm gonna list like the
supernova event something we don't have
to worry about that one we should be
okay okay um
and if it does happen maybe it'll just
kill us instantly and we won't even
notice hopefully
because i got bills brandon and i don't
want to pay them
and if the supernova goes off and i have
to pay my bills i'm going to be
i'm going to be pissed at him like
floating in the void like getting
freaking
statements t-mobile still sending me
bells i'm like there's no ozone there
how are you still sending me bills sally
may's like i know the earth isn't here
but come on
you still got student worlds
[Music]
yeah so speaking of things that will
eventually be extinguished mt
be sure to check out our limited edition
loki merch available at
rockstarsmerch.com okay we got t-shirts
stickers
buttons hats and hoodies and they're not
gonna last much longer than the six
episodes of loki
and they may even be gone before then so
get cracking and grab yourself some cool
merch
while also being helpful to this channel
so we can keep making all the cool stuff
you like
head on over to newrockstarsmerch.com so
that's my list
of possible apocalyptic events our bleak
future that loki has presented
and i think a few of these are pretty
possible so i don't know
you know maybe once loki is done you
know take that last ride at it
live long and prosperous that's what i
gotta say i hope we live long for a very
long time because
yeah i mean god you know what let's just
i the only thing that we should probably
take for this video is just
take every day um as a gift because it's
a beautiful thing that's a blessing it
is really
beautiful that we get to wake up see a
beautiful sunrise and not die
it's great eventually that sun will go
supernova and kill us all but
we'll be long gone not my problem not my
problem
but only metaphorically all right um
[Laughter]
anyways before we dive into our bite
size questions next some words from the
folks that help make
big question possible starting with cuts
clothing a lot of folks are starting to
do more in-person work and having to put
on non-pajamas for the first time in
months which is really unfun
not not great i'm so sorry um you don't
want to look like you just rolled out of
bed but you also don't have to sacrifice
comfort
for timeless style for that there's cuts
clothing the folks at cut's clothing
have taken a classic men's fashion style
the plain tee and refined it combining
premium quality with a minimalist
aesthetic cuts founder steve borelli
reinvented the t-shirt and made what gq
magazine calls
the only shirt worth wearing their
signature pika pro tri blend tea
is a bold new take on a classic design i
have some cut shirts myself
and they both look great and also feel
really nice on my skin and my skin
likes nice clothes on it so i'm very
grateful for that and philip is a big
fan
of the way they fit and he cares a lot
about that kind of stuff as he should
because
he's a very strong muslim man he
probably looks very good in shirts
he's a beautiful man a beautiful man
this is the second time
in the week that i've complimented
philip's physique anyway
can't help it it demands to be
complimented it's true he earned it it's
not just a lifestyle it's not just
clothing
it's office leisure apparel for the
sport of business
get 15 off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
big question that's cuts clothing dot
com
slash big question for 15 off the only
shirt
worth wearing the question would also
like to thank credit karma
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
and now they want to help you
even more with a credit karma money
spend account you could be rewarded for
good money habits
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchases
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimbursements on items
up to five thousand dollars
just pay with your debit card and if you
win you'll be notified on the spot and
your instant karma cash will be added
back to your spend account credit karma
money has already given away over three
million dollars in instant karma
open your fdic insured spend account for
free no minimum balance requirements no
overdraft fees and free withdrawals at
over
50 000 atms right now visit
creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com
win money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma
no purchase necessary exclusion and
terms apply c
rules banking services provided by mvb
bank
incorporated member fdic maximum balance
and transfer limits apply
okay mt it's time to dive into our bite
size question and i got a good one for
you today
this question is in thor ragnarok what
happened to
gungmir when asgard was destroyed would
it have survived that event and still be
floating around in space somewhere
and this was asked by the real odin 73
on twitter probably once his gun mirror
okay oh [ __ ] the real odin we about to
get that back for you bro
that's a real good question the real
odin 73 the olden spear that we see in
thor
four of the dark world and thor ragnarok
is named gangneer it is made of an
extremely tough metal called uru
just like mjolnir and stormbreaker and
it is a symbol of asgardian kingship
in the mcu gungner dates all the way
back to at least
bore thor's grandfather and odin's dad
and boar
fought a mighty war i don't know if you
remember in thor 2
i love that rhyme fought a mighty war my
father
and he of course wielded it against
malekith and the dark elves and it would
then be passed down to odin
and became his main weapon as we see him
wield it a few times in the films and
when loki takes over asgard
while his papo is taking a long nap he
wields gangner as the ruler of asgard
and he even uses it to kill his real
daddy
laufey who's laughing now not you
sorry
[Laughter]
the spear is able to project powerful
amounts of energy and can even channel
dark energy to act as a teleporter
similar to the bifrost and odin uses
gangneer to send four back to earth to
retrieve loki in avengers and gunner can
also be used to operate
the bifrost just in case you know you
misplace heimdall sword even though it's
it's pretty fairly in there but gun gear
can be used to replace it
if needed and of course the last we saw
of gangneer was
in for ragnarok with four faced off with
his sister
hella in the throne room and he kind of
just leaves it there while dealing with
her and then serder comes along and
does his whole destroying asgard to fill
the prophecy thing which is you know
i mean that's what he was meant to do he
was pretty excited about it i mean he's
pretty happy and i'm happy for him he
was very happy he was like wow i'm doing
it i'm doing it
i'm finally doing i'm killing these rich
[ __ ] kill them all
how fulfilling right he's living his
dreams i hope he's happy now
like what did he do after we should do
like this there should be a marvel short
of like
certain goes to disney world i can't
believe i did it
but maybe my ex-wife will respect me now
he's just like tgi fridays like
i'm gonna destroy these mozzarella
sticks like that
i just i want a certain show in the
style of the modoc show that would be
hilarious
so is gun near gone forever it's
possible it was destroyed but
like most enchanted items in comics
these important things tend to stick
around until we know that it was
completely destroyed like you know
mjolnir i wouldn't count it out of the
picture i mean it's probably floating
around in space somewhere like i said
before
it's very very strong stuff uru is
really really
powerful stuff so it's going to be
really hard to to get rid of that and
like as we know in thor 4
mjolnir is coming back somehow so like
who's
here to stay in the marvel universe so
it's probably just floating around
hopefully uh gore doesn't have it
because if gore has that [ __ ]
that's a problem that could be a real
problem or maybe some ravagers picked it
up while sifting through the wreckage of
the destruction of asgard
i i could see uh staccar wielding the
guggeneer he could do it sylvester
stallone
playing around with it do you want to do
another little star wars kid actually no
but either way
we could see governor in for love and
thunder again hopefully
not in the hands of gore the god butcher
because he already has that necro sword
so we don't need to
do wielding action there maybe they'll
get it to valkyrie somehow and she can
wield it
on earth oh my god that'd be so sick
she deserves it i hope she goes and gets
it honestly no make someone else go get
it she's the boss now someone else can
go get it
she'll send the flying horse to go get
it right it's somewhere over there
it's somewhere up there go get it figure
it out
that is it for that question but thank
you for that question it was really good
but do you know what part of the show it
is brandon
it's time for the box of scraps
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave
with the boxes crabs but today's
box of scraps question brandon is what
type of apocalypse do you think
you'd be most likely to survive that's a
good question empty
it could be any type of epoch any type
of apocalypse um
you know i think i would do pretty well
if there was some sort of
um lego apocalypse where everything
let's say one of these supernova pops
off right everything gets turned to lego
uh and i have to rebuild society i think
i could do that you know i think i could
you know form myself a little lego car a
little lego house
little lego gun that shoot a little lego
bullets you know i think i would do all
right
it'd be kind of like a real world like
minecraft minecraft right like just kind
of putting everything back together it's
building it up
the legopalips i i dig
dude i hope i make it to the lips
cool i feel like will everyone mutate
and get those weird little
crab yeah we're gonna have those
we'll be able to change our hair however
we want it
i mean yeah i mean that'd be a pretty
good uh stress a less stress i feel
if you have like interchangeable lego
parts you know right
so when you sit down in something you're
gonna have to shove like the little lego
parts into your life yeah
that's going to be a paragraph we got
like buttholes now right but
cheek holes i mean we always had
buttholes but we have butt cheek holes
now so three holes on the posterior
very uh interesting anyway the lego
apocalypse i like that one
honestly i i feel like i would probably
do well
in no i mean i don't think there's any
in most apocalyptic scenarios i'm god
i'm a gunner right
i think i probably do well in a zombie
apocalypse scenario because like
you know everyone says that but like i
feel like if you think
really rationally and just go to an area
where there are no people then you'll be
good like just climb a mountain and live
off the land like grab a bunch of books
on like how to survive off the land
and just go up and because like let's be
real
if these are american zombies these
these guys are not climbing mountains
they're going to be like ah you know
i'm good
um so like i would just be chilling up
on a mountain with my uh
uh how to survive the apocalypse for
dummies that i stole from the library
not planning on returning um and i i
think it'd be pr i think i'd do pretty
good
especially because if they're the slow
zombies yes but if they're fast zombies
i'm done
yeah you know the fast zombies that's a
modern contrivance you know traditional
zombies are pretty slow
people always complain like why do they
always make such bad decisions in zombie
movies or like on the walking dead or
whatever it's because that makes for
good
entertainment you'll you don't want to
watch the zombie movie where people are
just successfully surviving it's a
boring yeah it's a
boring ass movie but i feel like if the
zombie apocalypse did happen
especially in america like in like south
america like the southern america
they would have a field day with that
[ __ ]
they would just shoot all the zombies
they would be gone
it'd be fine they would be 100 percent
right it's if i got turned into a zombie
i think i'd
i'd focus on mcdonald's rather than like
brains i just feel like big macs
like big mac line empty
i think zombies tend to like brain mac
instead
the i don't know that's clever like
that's pretty good i hear it's delicious
but yes that's buy it and that is it for
this episode of big question and i want
to give a special thank you to
off-screen producer brandon for joining
me this episode thank you brandon thank
you for having me empty this has been a
blast
sorry it was so bleak but how much dude
i learned a lot
i literally learned so much so thank you
for just keeping it real it's just
keeping it real but again
at the end let's just enjoy the moment
now people just don't think about the
apocalypse just
enjoy the moment now and do what you can
to stop the apocalypse from happening
anyway follow brennan at grin and
barrack on twitter and then you can
follow me at
mastertainment on twitter as well if you
want to you know read a bunch of
nonsense nonsense
but most importantly follow new
rockstars on twitter but most
importantly on youtube
and make sure to hit that notification
bell so you can get notifications
whenever we upload
a video and make sure to send us your
big questions using the hashtag
bigquestion subscribe to our podcast
feed and leave us a nice rating and
review that always helps us out a lot we
really appreciate it
and yeah we'll catch you guys later
[Music]
peace
do
you